وقبل حديث عن مرتزقه فاجنر الذين ومعظمهم
مودانين وافقوا على اطلاق سراح مشروط
بخدمه على الجبهات الاماميه والالتزام
طبعا بقواعد قد يجرهم كسرها الى حبل
المشنقه فهؤلاء العناصر الذين يعضا اليهم
التقدم الروسي في سوليدار وباخمود يخضعون
لقواعد صارمه ربما تتفاوت مع الجنود الروس
المجموعات المهاجمه لا تنسحب بدون امر
وتنطبق عقوبه الاعدام فوريه على اي شخص اا
ينسحب من غير تصريح او من دون التعرض
لاصابه مقاتله غالبا ما يتركون شرحاهم
خلفهم لساعات حيث يمنع المشاه الهجوميين
من حمل الجارحه من ساحه المعركه بمفردهم
نظرا الى ان مهمتهم الرئيسيه تتمثل في
مواصله الهجوم حتى يتم تحقيق الهدف وفي
حال فشل الهجوم لا يسمح لهم بالت الا في
الليل فاجنر تنشر قواتها في مجموعات
متنقله من حوالي 12 شخصا او اقل تكتيك
يرجح خبراء مشاهدين ان تقلده القوات
الروسيه المدنون يشكلون الموجه الاولى اي
الهجوم ويتكبدون 80% من الخسائر يتبع ذلك
مقاتلون اكثر خبره مسلحين بمعدلات التصوير
الحراري ومعدات الرؤيه الليليه هذا واظهرت
تحليلات لصور اقمار صناعيه ومقاطع فيديو
نشرتها نيويورك تايمز توسع المدافن التي
تستخدمها مجموعه فاجنر وبسرعه وقدرت بنحو
سبعه اضعاف خلالها شهرين